I think a back story is important I
think I know for me that people have
developed a sort of tempest in a teapot
kind of lower about how I got published
and you know it can be very frustrating
because it can cannibalize and find its
way into legitimate reviews you like to
think that book review sections exist in
sort of a vacuum it's like 12 Angry Men
somewhere but it's not they read the
same thing you read and the same thing I
read and so that's just annoying in
terms of it used just real estate wise
it takes and can take up a lot of a
review but that review might not have
existed were it not for the back story
so it's totally impossible to tell how
much it's helping and how much it's
hurting to have that kind of thing in
terms of image in terms of appearance I
think it's important for I guess hype
reasons it's a it's a vehicle to get
people to the to the book but so is
everything the cover is a vehicle on the
title everything is a foot in the door
and then if you walk into an empty room
you leave that's really all there is to
it it's all there is to marketing it's
funny my boss always says that the
funniest thing about our jobs is that no
one has any idea what we do which is
true because you'll you know there'll be
a lot of people who say well can we do
this with this book don't you think the
wall street journal should should cover
it don't you think it should be on Oprah
and yes I do you think those things and
it's it's difficult I mean the best part
of publicity the one its most fun is
when its no balls and it's like I mean
it's such an uphill climb especially
paperback publicity is such an uphill
climb and it's it's really difficult but
then if a book starts to take off and
you have one big media hit and then
another my job gets really fun
and it's like Chum in the water and you
start looking around you're like okay
who hasn't covered this and it's the
best feeling ever because you actually
feel like you're getting someone to read
something that you care about you know
then the next day you go back to being a
glorified Avon lady Hey oh I'm just
calling people and then you know begging
them for just a little bit of coverage
of this you know reissue of a collection
of Icelandic short stories please God I
don't even know what that means I mean I
feel like you know I feel like I have a
good relationship and really enjoy my
job and have a good relationship with
the people that make those decisions and
when you do this job for long enough you
can work it backwards you can see a
byline or an article and you can see how
it was pitched you can see well someone
clearly approach that person to write
this piece they didn't pitch it or you
can see how they needed to get something
in order to do it and for in my case to
me it seems crystal clear that I have a
combination of really good work contacts
and a couple of sincere friends who work
at the New York Observer and I think
that they were in a meeting and someone
said Sloan has a book coming out and so
when else said hey I know her and you
know I think it's a little bit more than
that I think a little bit more
widespread I don't want to sell myself
too short but not by a whole lot I think
that there are people that I mean the
true most popular pub I know is it isn't
Ken sunshine or somebody like that the
most popular publicist you know i will
say that sweet smells sweet smell of
success is one of my favorite movies
it's a fantastic movie but I don't think
I'm quite at the level where someone's
going to let me hijack their column and
let me
right